[Music]
sunday was another sad day in san
francisco two more walgreens stores
closed up shop another location will
close later this week
these are among a string of closings in
the city 22 walgreens have closed
already due to the effective
decriminalization of shoplifting in the
state a representative from one of the
local walgreens branches in the city
said in a statement to abc quote due
largely to ongoing organized retail
theft we have made the difficult
decision to close five stores across san
francisco five more stores anyway each
store will transfer prescriptions to a
nearby walgreens location within a mile
radius and we expect to place the
store's team members in other nearby
locations organized retail theft
continues to be a challenge facing
retailers across san francisco and we
are not immune to that retail theft
across our san francisco stores has
continued to increase in the past few
months to five times our chain average
now walgreens is not the only chain
affected the safeway location in the
city was recently forced to cut its
hours due to off the charts quote
unquote shoplifting
now that store had been open 24 hours
but it's just not possible to run a
24-hour operation in a city where theft
is legal you know
we've seen how bad it could be in the
middle of the day now imagine 3am how
bad it must be so now that store will
close at 9pm each night which means lots
of employees at that location will we
can assume lose their jobs
a target store also closed recently for
the same reason and it's not just big
chains being slammed either every day it
seems there's another video of somebody
walking into a random local store
somewhere in the city
and walking out with armfuls of
merchandise here's the latest footage
from some boutique shop in in town we'll
watch this
[Music]
okay so the guy walks in he gets a nice
greeting from the the woman running
store kind of looks around like a
shopkin shopping and uh
he is shopping in us in a certain way
yeah why not grab all the jeans
just grabs a whole stack of jeans
most of those won't fit him but
[Music]
and then grab some other clothes and
walks right out
and then you always see the impotent
employee walking
after the person is left
the employee shows up in the frame on
the phone who are you who are you gonna
call the ghostbusters
there's no one to call here no no one's
gonna no one's gonna arrest that guy no
one's gonna prosecute him
and the cops won't arrest him because
he's not going to be prosecuted
and we know this problem is not
contained to san francisco similar
scenes have unfolded in chicago miami
new york los angeles all of these cities
have cut back on or entirely given up on
prosecuting so-called non-violent
criminals which has given those
criminals the green light to do what
they do best
shocking result here
apparently when you don't prosecute
certain crimes you get more of those
crimes
now these videos are generally shared by
people who are outraged by what they see
and i understand the outrage it offends
us to see scumbag criminals running amok
doing what they please with no
consequence
we want to see them punished and that is
a good and properly ordered desire it's
a desire for justice and we should
desire that
but what we should not feel is any
sympathy for the quote unquote victims
here
as mean as it might sound to say it
now it's good to feel sympathy
um
generally that's a good instinct to have
but we need to get past that in this
case
because we have to remember that the
people of california quite literally
asked for this
so yes i am victim blaming
very often victim blaming is appropriate
very often uh we find that
in many types of situations
the victims deserve the quote-unquote
victims have a certain amount of the
onus falls on them as well and that is
certainly the case here
because they went to the polls the
people of california did and they voted
on a ballot initiative to effectively
decriminalize shoplifting so this wasn't
even a case of voting for some crazy
left-wing politician who then goes and
put these puts these policies in place
that's the way it's worked in some of
these other cities
and there the citizens are getting what
they asked for too but in california
the proposal was on the ballot they
selected it
they chose it
they said yeah that sounds good i want
that
they sewed and now they reap
it sounds not only harsh but perhaps
nihilistic to say that we should simply
sit back now and let the left-wing
cities burn
but it's not nihilistic at all it's the
opposite really
we are letting people experience the
consequences of their own actions
we are letting them discover that their
actions matter their choices matter
and that is not nihilism
we are letting them have what they chose
we are allowing them to take their nice
sounding liberal theories and experience
them in reality
they're learning the hard way
because that's the only way they will
learn if they ever do it all
this is one of the reasons why i don't
understand the conservatives who were
very eager to get a republican elected
as governor in california
it was probably never going to happen
and it probably never will happen at
this point
but there are a lot of republicans there
were very like they wanted to get larry
elder in there they wanted a republican
but why should we want that
why should we want a republican sitting
at the top of this dung keep
why should we want a republican
overseeing a collapsing system
no california is a left-wing dystopia
it's everything that happens when
leftists are allowed to do as they
please why should we want a republican
anywhere near that
he can't save california why should he
try
see leftism proliferates in part because
the people who support its policies and
ideas have rarely been allowed to
experience them in their fruition
we we we have we have been saving them
from themselves
we've been standing in the gap largely
because we have to live in this society
too it's one thing for them to reap
their fruits
it's another for us to to reap them too
but as the sane people flee the
dystopian hellscapes like california
there is now finally an opportunity for
us to say okay have it your way do as
you please
i wish it didn't have to be this way but
it does
let them lay in the bed they've made
let california become everything they
want it to be
so that maybe they can discover that
they never really wanted it at all
i think that's the only way forward
it's the only way
and that's why i must say that san
francisco and california are by their
own doing
officially canceled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated